what brought you to Islam I mean baby
before you got all these degree all
these degrees degrees and whatnot I mean
there was a point at what point did you
determine yeah but at what point did you
decide because everyone and that's one
thing people even they were all born as
we say on the Fatah you know submissive
to the crater then the soul you know
gets tempted by the little things out
there and whatnot and then a person has
to come to the realization at one point
is this the truth because a lot of
people going through the rituals but at
one point and some people think oh this
is inherited you know what I mean so I'm
just gonna go through the rituals they
really truly haven't submitted I'm sure
you come across people like this at what
point in your life
did you realize this is the true from
the Creator because then you probably go
through the the thoughts like how do I
not know how do I know that Christianity
is not the way how do I know Buddha's
are not the way there's all these
different religions and then a person
has some self-doubt but at what point
did you come to know that indeed this is
from the crater and there is no doubt
about it
when I hear a long story then huh in
short a condensed version well because
people look at you now and they say okay
maybe I can't achieve that I can't get
to where he said he's any mom he's a
person you know you guys send people
give like some other clergy they've
three people from the Hellfire and or
and give them a given paradise you get
those guys oh you wouldn't do that you
know I just want to tell you this a lot
of people don't know this about me and
this is amazing now I'm going to open up
originally I used to be a tour guide in
Egypt you know some guy who takes
tourists around and you know and show
them that very much this is the pyramids
was built yeah and you know normally the
main business for a tour guide is to
sell gold mmm
cartouche and you know hurrah glyphic
yeah riding because we make a lot of
commission you know a lot of so for you
to sell it you have to wear gold and you
know you were all like all right up oh
yeah you were enough yet so I speak
German too so we ended up with that
group coming from Germany and don't feel
bad because a couple a few weeks ago I
had a share also a shaker
he used to have gold teeth in his mouth
so they requested to meet a famous clerk
he passed away may Allah have mercy on
him his name is Muhammad metallic Shara
we have enough urine anymore he excelled
in the field of deaf sphere even though
he's a shoddy Lapita and he's a shoddy
lucky then the students would know what
I'm talking about
yeah and tablet man had his cellophane
and I said I feel lucky there and if he
lets my Asif had specially once comes
with the names and the attributes in
particular but I had very high regard
for this year because I used to hear him
all the time I I just used to love him
dearly so finally I'm getting this
opportunity to actually go sit in front
of him the group requested to meet with
him as a non-muslim group in order to
ask him questions about Islam so I said
man I kid of course I assume that I will
be the guy to translate the conversation
between because he speaks Arabic but
then I called and I found out that he
has his own interpreter he doesn't trust
anyone else smart yeah because it's
really correct it was you know religious
vocabularies are totally different to
touristic and history you know history
weak abilities so in any rate I said ok
I'm just gonna go sit in front of him so
I went and I sat in front of the group
so normally he would speak in Arabic and
this his interpreter would translate so
I'm sitting in front of him and as he's
talking in Arabic I'm doing like I'm
nodding you know I'm I'm agreeing with
him I'm loving it I'm you know I'm
really loving it you know he thought
that I'm German because of the way I
look you know I had gel in my hair and
Flowery turned a shirt and I open my
chest you know yeah showing there that
chest with the gold were you submitting
at that time no so you hadn't come fully
to Islam no ok so that's what I hear you
opened up a can so that's fine yeah so
then I kept nodding so he was
very surprised to assume that a German
is a jerk well he assumed that yeah then
he asked me do you understand what I'm
saying because I'm nodding I said half
adult [ __ ] yes I do
are you a Muslim Abney my son are you a
Muslim I said yes here is it what are
you don't you said Allah Allah he said
it in a very fatherly way just to show
you that subhanAllah it is like a
concern like a loving way a loving way
look look the belief in a second did he
have me like he's worried about you see
your facial expression why why are you
doing this to yourself my son
Wow mostly why are you doing this
looking like Elvis Presley or somebody
else
why that's word you know changed me I
actually I I remember this I'm on rise
the Quran in 13 months you know how were
you at that time I was in my late
twenties you know and and and and you
know just to show you you know how that
was is through softness and yeah there's
hope for everyone yeah look at that I
mean that connects more now people can
probably relate to you more because
there's a lot of people following that
way you know something's so funny sure
so I was in America I came to America
and then I started learning and
memorizing and all that learning the
Deen
so I started having a beard so when you
arrive at the Cairo Airport the people
with the beard they normally take them
to a special place to you know check
them out and so forth so the guy from
the like what equals the CIA in Egypt
there I was sitting out there what's
your name because he has no record for
me out there you know for for them I'm
I'm the ideal citizen you know I'm a
touristic guy and I'm somebody who's you
know who's into that world I mean the
guy wears gold and that's the modern
citizen that he wants so what is your
name my name is karima soso I was eight
were you gradually did you graduate from
a faculty of tourism and
hotel business then he asked what are
you doing to yourself now he's telling
the opposite the shakes the bomb is left
circularly and these are my see these
are Muslims Muslims you see so he's
telling me the same exact line that the
sheep use but of course he used it in a
authoritarian kind of you know you know
he used it that I mean Philip psyckadeli
why did you do this to yourself you
having a beard you look like a Muslim
now why are you doing this to yourself
has the people asking you have they
truly submitted to the Creator no they
are having the job but just to show you
how so subhanAllah he immediately got me
to recall that same sentence so that
sentence changed me now I'm being tested
will you change back the same sentence
and alhamdulillah I'm still here and I'm
making dua that I continue and I'm doing
I mean this is wonderful to hear I mean
I think the people hear this especially
people who are kind of going through the
same struggles and they look at you and
they can relate right you don't seem
somebody too far far away from them yeah
so back to what I said are you thinking